hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast fundamentals of flow cytometry
from fluorescence to function I am Judy
or arc of levers and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo fisher scientific
thermo fisher scientific is the world
leader in serving science with revenues
of 17 billion and approximately 50,000
employees in 50 countries the company's
mission is to enable its customers to
make the world healthier cleaner and
safer thermo fisher scientific helps its
customers to accelerate life sciences
research solve complex analytical
challenges improve patient diagnostics
and increase laboratory productivity
through its premier brands thermo
scientific applied biosystems in
nitrogen Fisher Scientific and unity lab
Sciences the company offers an unmatched
combination of innovative technologies
purchasing convenience and comprehensive
support for more information please
visit www com we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker Jolene
Bradford MLS ascp Jolene Bradford is an
associate director for strategic
collaborations in biosciences division
of thermo fisher scientific in Eugene
Oregon
she joined the company in 2001 and has
developed numerous new reagents and
assays for the flow cytometry platform
well versed in fluorescent assays Jolene
has provided numerous webinars and
seminars on the topics and has been an
invited instructor at many flow
cytometry training courses and workshops
in the US and abroad more recently she
has been involved in developing acoustic
cytometry and instrumentation and
consults on applications prior to
joining thermo fisher scientific she
performed clinical laboratory testing as
a specialist in hematology and flow
cytometry in 2014 Jolene earned the
certified saitama saitama triste
international credential I will now turn
it over to Jolene Bradford for her
presentation alright well thank you for
that nice introduction and welcome to
everyone joining this webinar
introducing flow cytometry I'd like to
start out by introducing the protein and
cellular analysis business of thermo
fisher scientific this is designed to
really help meet all of your fluorescent
needs whether it's through
instrumentation for flow cytometry
imaging high content imaging or for
reagents assays and antibodies to help
you with your research i'll be
discussing the basics of flow cytometry
today just part of our commitment to you
to help provide solutions with every
step along the flow cytometry workflow
from designing your experiments through
sample prep different assays to
detection data analysis and on to
service and support so today we will be
discussing the following topics I'll be
describing what flow cytometry is and go
over fluorescence basics well look at
the components of a flow cytometers look
how data is displayed discuss
compensation and how to perform that
and they look at different types of
controls that are needed for a flow
cytometry experiment so where does the
term flow cytometry come from well saito
means cell and metry means measurement
so cytometry means the measurement of a
cell very simply the word flow is used
because cells are measured as they flow
through a fluid stream into a light
source and are measured flow cytometers
are used in a wide range of applications
and this makes it one of the most useful
and versatile platforms available the
plus I Tom eter performs analysis by
passing thousands of cells per second
through a laser beam and capturing the
light that emerges from each cell as it
passes through the ability to perform
measurements on single cells thousands
or even millions of cells in a sample
makes flow cytometry a very powerful
platform available the data generated
can be analyzed statistically by
software to report on the cellular
characteristics and most of the
measurements use some type of
fluorescent label some of the advantages
of flow cytometry this records data from
single cells we can make measurements on
large numbers of cells and populations
of cells thousands of cells even
millions of cells can be analyzed very
rapidly and rich statistical analysis on
these cell populations can be achieved
and because it is single cells that are
measured it can reveal the heterogeneity
within a population there is the ability
to multiplex looking at many parameters
at the same time and this allows
all sub populations of cells to be
identified flow cytometry is ideally
suited for blood and other cells in
suspension but it's certainly not
limited to cells in suspension as cells
can come from tumors or samples that are
adherent cells there is the ability to
archive standardized files and this
gives the flexibility to be able to
analyze and reanalyze data in the future
so fluorescence is the result of a
process that certain molecules contain
these are called fluorophores the
absorption spectrum and the emission
spectrum are both critical to
understanding how flow cytometry works a
fluorescent probe is a flora for that is
designed to localize within a specific
region or respond to specific stimulus
I'll go over all of these in more detail
in the coming slides so wavelength is
the distance that light travels on one
vibration cycle the distance is
expressed dynamometers the visible light
spectrum is composed of wavelengths of
light ranging from approximately 400
nanometers up to 700 nanometers light
waves with shorter wavelengths have
higher frequency and higher energy light
waves with longer wavelengths have lower
frequency and lower energy flow
cytometry is dependent upon the control
collection and separation of light
so here's what fluorescence is a 404 is
a molecule that is capable of
fluorescein in its ground state the 44
molecule is in a stable configuration
and it does not fluoresce goodnight from
an external source such as a laser
excites the molecule the molecule
absorbs the light energy the energy
absorbed if the energy is absorbed is
efficient to the molecule it helps it to
reach a higher energy state and this is
called the excited state this process is
known as excitation next the floor for
can rearrange itself from this
semi-stable excited state back to the
ground state and excess energy can be
released and this is released as emitted
light the emitted light is of lower
energy and thus longer wavelengths than
the absorbed light so we can summarize
this cyclical process as excitation of a
floor for through absorption of light
energy and there's a transient excited
lifetime with some loss of energy and
then a return of the fluorophore to its
ground state which is accompanied by
emission of light the emission maximum
for the 44 is always at a longer
wavelength thus it has lower energy than
the absorbed light or the excitation
wavelength and the difference between
the excitation and the emission
wavelengths is what is called the Stoke
shift fluorophores can absorb a range of
wavelengths of light energy and this is
called the excitation range fluorophores
emit a range of wavelengths and this is
called the
range within these ranges there is the
maximum for each the excitation and the
emission because the excitation and
emission wavelengths are different the
absorbed in the emitted light are
detected as different colors on the
visible spectrum so this is an example
of an excitation and emission spectra of
the alexa fluor 488 die the spectra of a
floor of a floor floor contain important
practical information about what
wavelengths of light we need to supply
and detect in order to use that floor
for effectively so here we see the
excitation max is 494 nanometers and the
emission max is 5 17 nanometers and the
accompanied curves underneath those show
that the spectrum for each so the
excitation and the emission spectra must
be examined carefully especially when
choosing two or more fluorophores in the
same experiment so that the 44 s can be
excited in a manner that will generate
distinct emissions spectra viewers like
the one offered on a thermo fisher
website i'm very helpful with this this
is an example from the spectra viewer
and here again we are looking at the
spectra of 244 alexa fluor 488 and alexa
fluor 647 i'm also showing the different
wavelengths of lasers that are used to
excite each of these individual four
fours before 88 blue laser and the 638
red laser so building on this the
emission spectra for both the 488 and
the lexa 46 47 floors are now added in
our online for s expect reviewer can be
very helpful for creating all of the
different fluorophores in your
experiment and also for your convenience
there is a spectrum your mobile app so
that you can put it on your mobile
device so now I'm showing just the
emission profiles of the two particular
dies and I've added in the collection
bandpass filters that are commonly used
in flow cytometers so you can see which
portion of the emission spectrum is
being collected by the instrument so
flow cytometry is a technology that can
simultaneously measure and analyze many
characteristics of single cells it's
basically composed of three components
the fluidics the optics and the
electronics fluidics introduce the cells
for interrogation with the laser the
optics generate and collect the light
signals and the electronics convert the
optical signals to proportional
electronic signals for analysis so this
shows the primary systems of the site
ometer the fluidics move the sample to
the interrogation point then it also
takes the sample off to waste the optics
include laser light source for light
scatter and fluorescence and also help
to direct and gather the light in the
detectors and then finally the
electronics and peripheral computer
system convert the signals from the
detectors into digital data so the
purpose of a fluidics system is to
transport the particles or cells in a
fluid stream to the laser beam for
interrogation most often the sample is
injected into a stream of sheath fluid
for optimal data quality the particles
should be in the very center of the
laser beam when one particle should move
through the laser beam at one time and
fluidic systems really need to be free
of air bubbles and debris so here is a
diagram on the left of the fluidic
screen here we see the sheath and the
sample stream on the right are the
fluidic bottles that are associated with
the NB trogen attune NXT flow cytometer
benchtop cytometers like this are very
popular now with the all of the fluidics
located on board so the fluidic systems
include the sheath fluid which is
usually assault suspension and in most
systems the cells are completely
surrounded by the sheath fluid the cells
are particles and suspension flow in a
single file through the laser beam where
they scatter light and they emit
fluorescence so the excitation optics
help create this illumination region
this includes lasers and diodes includes
lenses to help shape and focus the laser
beam the collection optics route the
light signals to specific detectors and
include a system of optical mirrors and
filters to route the light to the
designated detectors this is a laser
light is a coherent light that is used
by flow cytometers to excite fluorescent
dyes and characterize the particles as
they pass through the laser beam so here
we see some of the most commonly used
laser excitation sources but it's
certainly not an exhaustive list of
laser wavelengths and as systems become
more
and have the ability to measure more and
more parameters number of lasers
peripheral cytometry can increase in
multi laser cytometers they have
generally speaking spatially separated
lasers so that each cell passes through
each laser interrogation point at
different times the information obtained
at each laser interrogation a point is
aligned over time so that can be
recorded at the same time for each cell
and this timing coordination is called
laser delay there are some flow
cytometers that use collinear lasers
instead but this complicates emission
and die selection and can complicate
data interpretation so generally
speaking spatially separated lasers are
preferred so this is an example of
optical filters on the left that are put
in place to help direct the appropriate
laser light to the appropriate detector
and then PMT detectors are shown on the
right that capture that light and then
convert it into pulse signals as cells
pass through a laser it refracts or
scatters light in all directions light
scattering occurs when the particle
deflects the laser light the extent to
which this occurs depends on the
physical properties of the cell or the
particle namely its size and internal
complexity forward scatter is also
called low angle light scatter and this
is the light that is scattered in the
forward direction as laser light strikes
the cell the magnitude of the forward
scatter is roughly proportional to the
size of the
particle but it's not an absolute
measurement side scatter is defined as
the light that is scattered at larger
angles generally speaking side scatter
is collected 90 degrees from the lasers
light path side scatter is indicative of
granularity and structural complexity
inside the cell or on the surface of the
cell just using white scatter such as
these plots here showing forward scatter
and side scatter to parameter plots just
these alone can help with the
differentiation of different cell types
in a mixed cell population so on the
Left we have nice whole blood and again
this is no fluorescent parameters but we
can see three distinct populations of
cells and on the right we see some
cultured jerk at T cells and as these
are aged so that there is a significant
dead cell population and you can see a
shifting of population just based on the
forward and side light scatter so the
interrogation point is really the heart
of the system this is where the laser
and the sample intersect and the optics
that collect the resulting light and
light scatter and the fluorescence occur
so for accurate data collection it's
important that the particles or the
cells are passed through the laser beam
one at a time most flow cytometers
accomplish this by injecting the sample
stream containing the cells into a
flowing stream of sheath fluid or saline
solution with hydrodynamic focusing the
sample is injected into a stream of
sheath fluid or it is completely
surrounded by the
chief the sample core is then centered
within the sheath fluid based on
principles relating to laminar flow the
sample remains separate but coaxial with
the sheath fluid the flow of sheath food
accelerates the particles and restricts
them to the center of the sample core
and this process is known as
hydrodynamic focusing at a low flow rate
the sample core is very narrow and the
particles interact with the laser beam
in an optimal manner to increase the
flow rate in a hydrodynamic system the
speed of the sample chord does not
change but rather the width of the
simple chord within the fluid stream
widens and this allows more cells to
enter the course train at a given moment
within with a wider sample core however
some cells will pass through the laser
beam off center and intercept the laser
in a less than optimal manner and this
creates variability of signal this
results in a wider distribution of data
and a resolution is decreased this
limitation this trade-off of speed and
sensitivity has largely been accepted by
the flow cytometry communicate community
so to obtain optimal Dana with the
lowest signal variability the
conventional flow cytometer must be run
in the lowest sample rate in 2010 a
breakthrough advancement was introduced
this uses acoustic sound waves to very
gently place the cells in the middle of
the fluid stream regardless of speed or
sample core with acoustic assisted
hydrodynamic focusing places the
particles into the center of the sample
stream
it's pre focused and then injected into
the sample stream which then provides
additional hydrodynamic pressure to
place the sample prior to interrogation
with the lasers so the combination of
these two forces results in narrow
particle stream and very uniform laser
illumination regardless of the sample
input so this allows no compromise
between data quality and sample flow
rate by uncoupling the cell alignment
from the sheath fluid from the sheet
flow so flow rates unimaginable for are
now possible up to ten times faster and
high quality data is still maintained at
these faster flow rates so this is an
end on view of a capillary running five
micron fluorescent beads first without
the acoustic forces and then with the
acoustic forces applied you can see
those beads go directly to the center of
the stream the acoustic forces are taken
off and then apply it again so again you
can see how these particles go directly
to the center of the fluid stream so
finally we have the electronics and
these electronics function to convert
optical signals to proportional
electronical signals this is also called
voltage pulses they allow us to analyze
the voltage pulse height area and width
and then we interface with the computer
for transfer of data and analysis so as
particles pass through the laser beam in
a fluid stream light signals are
generated and these signals are
converted to electronic signals and the
detectors a voltage pulse is created
so the data is processed to
simultaneously calculate the pulse area
the pulse height and the pulse width so
the height of the pulse is the amplitude
of the peak the area is the integrated
signal under the pulse peak and then the
width is the time that it takes for the
cell to pass through the laser many
cytometers were actually calculate the
width parameter however it is directly
measured with the attune NXT so
fluorescence data is collected in
generally the same way as we collect
forward and side scatter in a population
of labeled cells some of them will be
brighter than others as each cell
crosses the laser a fluorescent signal
is generated the fluorescent light is
directed to the appropriate detector
where it is then translated into a
voltage pulse that is proportional to
the amount of fluorescence light that
has been emitted so flow cytometric data
is stored according to defined standards
called flow cytometry standard files or
FCS files this allows for a common and
consistent language to describe the flow
cytometry data the name list mode file
is sometimes used because the data are
acquired as a list of values for each
parameter or from each detector
so histogram is a very common form of
data presentation a histogram allows for
the view of a single parameter against
number of events it can also be called a
single parameter plot they come in a
variety of different sizes and shapes
depending on the data that is being
acquired as seen in the examples at the
bottom here so lines can be drawn around
a population in order to distinguish
them from one another on a histogram and
then to parameter plots are often called
dot plots or density plots so here we
see the exact same data shown as a dot
plot and as a density plot so this is a
type of graphical representation of two
parameter data where each axis
represents the signal intensity of one
of the parameters and each dot in the
plot corresponds to one of the cells the
density plot takes this and adds signal
intensity to the display two parameter
can also be called bivariate plots and
here's some additional examples of a
density plot on the left and a dot plot
on a right
regions and gates are commonly used to
help define and identify different
populations in a multicolored experiment
the most popular application is to use
of gates in a sequential order so that
you can limit the data display and
define the parameters for statistical
analysis so this is it is an example of
using a gate so here we have a mixed
population in the plot on the top a
region is drawn around the lymphocytes
and then the plots on the bottom are
gated on the memphis aight so this
display would reflect the fluorescence
properties of only the lymphocytes so
compensation is a process by which
spillover fluorescence is removed from
secondary parameters so that fluorescent
values for the parameter reflect only
the fluorescence of the primary
fluorophore the potential consequence of
uncorrectable over is a false positive
signal it is possible to eliminate this
electronically by removing the signal
through a process called compensation
although many instruments and software
packages can perform an automated
compensation for researchers it is still
important to understand the basic
principles so let's look at what
fluorescence is and how to compensate
fluorescence spillover so in a perfect
world the fluorescence emission profile
for each individual floor for it would
be a very narrow intense peak that are
well separated from each other something
like what we
here in reality however the fluorophores
have broad emission peaks so here we see
the emission profiles of the alexa fluor
488 died and the RFI coherent or RPE
died for a proper interpretation of the
data collected we need to be sure that
the light being recorded for the alexa
fluor 488 die is really coming from the
alexa die and not from our PE and to
accurately record the fluorescent signal
for a given floor for we need to correct
for the emission signal and as
correction is called compensation so the
saitama to records fluorescence using an
emission filter chosen to correct to
collect the maximum amount of light
coming from the floor for of interest
and to exclude as much light as possible
from other floors so here we see the
alexa fluor 488 fluorescence being
collected with a 5 30 nanometer bandpass
filter and the RPE fluorescence is being
collected with a 585 bandpass filter
while each of these filters efficiently
captures the emission peak of the target
flora for each band pass also collects a
little bit of the other floor for due to
the spectral over overlap of the
emission profiles and this overlap is
shown here in red so for this pair of
fluorophores the amount of spectral
overlap of the alexa dye into our PE is
greater and requires more compensation
than the amount of sterile overlap
generated from PE into the alexa fluor
detective detector so in order to see
the amount of compensation that is
required to collect for this
fluorescence over
we need single color samples either
Ellicott's of the same cell sample
stained with each floor for separately
or microspheres that capture an
individual reagent so in this example we
see a single color control we have cells
that are labeled with only the alexa
fluor 488 die it isn't however a two
parameter plot with the PE fluorescence
displayed on the y-axis we see both a
positivity positively labeled population
with a very bright fluorescence and also
a negative population however these same
cells emit fluorescence into the PE
detector and this results in this
apparent upward shift of the population
where there is no compensation applied
so when you see cells on this diagonal
it you often think of cells or the
experiment has not had compensation
applied so the signal occurs this way
because the tale of the alexa fluor
emission has the right wavelength to be
collected in the PE detector and this
incidental collection of the alexa for
fluorescence into the PE detector could
erroneously increase the amount of PE
signal assigned to the cells if left
uncommon sated so the plot on the Left
shows uncommon sated data while the plot
on the right shows what the data looks
like after correct compensation has been
applied on although the signal is real
we are detecting real light fluorescence
that is coming from the 488 die but it
cannot be correctly assigned to the rpd
label or the RPE detector
so let's talk about how to compensate a
negative control is used many mimic the
background fluorescence this can include
autofluorescence any nonspecific binding
and any non antigen specific binding the
positive fluorescence is always a
relative to the negative fluorescence a
negative control can either be unlabeled
cells or a microsphere or it can be
isotype cells so to set compensation
properly the use of a single color
positive control is required for each
flora for used in the experiment a
sample with just that one floor for is
prepared and the fluorescence is then
collected in all of the detectors used
in the experiment this way the
fluorescence spill over into all of the
other detectors can be determined it
does need to be the exact same floor
floor that you're using an experiment
for example a PC and Alexa 46 47 or two
fluorophores that are collected in the
same detector but the spectra of the two
are different and they will produce
different compensation values if you're
using a tandem die it is recommended
that you use the exact same rod of
tandem due to the high variability of
making the tandem itself so different
lots of tandem guys can produce
different compensation values the same
cells that are being tested in the
experiment can be used as a positive
control however cells can be problematic
if there is a low or absent expressing
antigen antibody capture beads can be
used and these provides some advantages
they can use the same reagent there are
lots of positive events
that are very bright remember
compensation controls the positive must
be matched to each experiment and it
needs to be at least as bright as the
reagent or the expression of that
reagent we used in the experiment so in
summary for compensation single color
controls are needed for each floor for
in the experiment the positive needs to
be at least as a bright as the
experimental sample it needs to be
spectrally matched to the experimental
reagent and the positive and the
negative controls are matched for
background fluorescence when we talk
about experimental controls we typically
talk about the single color compensation
troll controls which I've just described
FMO controls in a positive or biological
sample control so compensated data can
result in unexpected fluorescence
distribution called spread and the
spread of data can preclude adjustment
of the signal down to the level of the
autofluorescence found in unlabeled
cells so use of staining controls that
include all of the reagents except for
the one of interest are called
fluorescence minus 1 or fmo controls and
this allows for a precise definition to
delineate the positive and negative
populations and it also helps adjust for
the spread of the data isip type control
antibodies have no specificity for the
target cells within a particular
experiment yet they retain the non
specific characteristics of the
antibodies used in experiment although
widely used in the past their use today
is somewhat controversial their purpose
is to confirm the specificity of primary
antibody
finding that is not a result of
nonspecific FC binder FC receptor
binding to cells or to other cellular
protein interactions the isotype
antibody ideally matches the primary
antibodies host species or isotype and
conjugation format and that's needed to
accurately access assess the level of
specific binding FML controls are really
more accurate for mark replacement than
using isotype controls and are generally
preferred these days and then finally a
biological biological control that
provides biologically relevant
information should be included to ensure
your sample preparation staining
compensation and gating or performed as
expected so this brings us to the end of
our webinar thank you for joining me
today and I think we have some time for
a few questions thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can the first question is can you
explain what autofluorescence is sure so
autofluorescence is a term that is has
been given to describe the nap natural
fluorescence that occurs in cells
autofluorescence contributes to the
background signal and so thus it can be
a factor in the separation of separating
positive and negative
signals it basically can decrease the
functional signal resolution larger
cells have more autofluorescence in
general than smaller cells and laser
wavelengths that are lower generally
produce higher autofluorescence why is
it recommended to titrate antibodies
yeah that's a great question so
titration is is really a process of
identifying the best concentration to
use an antibody for a given a say the
vendors can make general recommendations
for guidance on what concentration to
use but it may not be appropriate for
your specific si doing an antibody
titration is really one of the most
basic tests done and flow cytometry the
process is fairly simple keeping the
cell concentration constant and also
keeping the conditions of labeling
constants such as temperature and time
of incubation even the volume of the
reaction and then you can make changes
in the concentration of the antibody
used and you can look at the difference
between the positive and the negative
signal make calculations around a signal
to background or stating index to really
find the most optimal tighter of
antibody or concentration of antibody
that's used for your particular
experiment
what is sorting so I think there was a
question around what is sorting and I
really didn't address what sorting is so
a sorter is a type of specialized flow
cytometers that can separate cells and
then collect them for downstream studies
most common the most common type of
sorting has a piezo-electric vibrating
mechanism that causes the stream of
cells to break into individual droplets
and each droplet will ideally have one
cell just before the stream breaks into
droplets the fluorescence is natured and
an electrical charge is placed on a
droplet that contains the cell of
interest so that it can be deflected for
collection so there's numerous orders
that are coming onto the market that use
microchip based sorting and there's a
whole variety of sorting options from
very simple to very complicated
instruments
okay we have time for one last question
and it is I've heard that it is
important to eliminate dead cells what
does this mean so that's a great
question especially with
immunophenotyping experiments it's
really important to identify dead cells
so that you can take them out of your
data analysis and this is because
antibodies have been shown to non
specifically bind to dense cells and
this can give you a false positive
reading so using a dead cell stain to
help identify dead cells you can get
them out and make your your data much
more accurate there's really two ways to
do this there are impermeable a ghasidas
that can be added to your cell prep as
the last step and not washed out there's
a number of choices like the site
oxidized or papetti iodide and these can
be used to help in your experimental
design there's also the live dead
fixable amine reactive dyes so these are
actually fixable so that you can use
these with experiments that use fix and
perm and looking at intracellular
targets they're all all of these dives
come in a variety of colors so that you
can use them in whatever experimental
design and however many colors you have
for your experiment and I'd suggest
again using aspect reviewer to put these
into your experimental design so
basically it's identifying dead cells so
you can eliminate them from your data
analysis to create the most accurate
data that you can
I would like to once again thank Jolene
Bradford for her presentation do you
have any final comments everyone for
joining us today and I just want to
thank everyone for joining me today and
I'd like to remind you that there are a
number of other webinars on the thermo
Fisher website around flow cytometry
these range from topics like cliff
eration apatow Sasaki biology and panel
design so look forward to interacting
with you in the future thank you thanks
again I would also like to thank our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
june twenty eight twenty seventeen you
will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you in this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
four of that announcement to colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
see you next time goodbye